So wouldn't it be good if in every society where every organization,
we had some people who specialized in,
uh,
specialized,
insane,
hey,
what are the opportunities?
And then we had other people as specialized in saying,
well,
but what are the risks?
And it just so happens that a lot of people have trouble doing all that in
themselves.
When we have systems that are well constituted with people who have different
personalities and different motives and goals,
we actually can get better.
We can have a discussion between them.
Yeah.
Well that's exactly why that it's for that precise reason that,
that I've been so interested in free speech as a,
as a,
as a value because well,
even on the economic front,
it's pretty obvious if you look at things economically,
that the entrepreneur types who start businesses are lumped in with the liberal
creative types.
We've done a lot of work on the prediction of entrepreneurial behavior and
ability and it's openness.
That's the big predictor.
It's not the only one.
It's openness an Iq fundamentally.
But for managerial and administrative expertise,
it's,
oh,
it's Iq and conscientiousness.
So the liberals start businesses and,
and,
but they can't run them because they're there,
their interests flipped and they don't have the organizational ability and the
conservatives can run them,
but they can't continue to transform and expand the,
yeah.
It Yin and Yang.
Yin and Yang.
Yup.
So,
so one more thing about what happened in Nazi Germany that it's very relevant
and interesting because it's,
it's useful to get these motives right.
You know,
first of all,
if,
if something disgusts you,
if something,
if you're afraid of something,
then you run away from it or you freeze.
But if something disgusts you,
you try to burn it or die or kill it.
Right.
You try to get rid of or expel it.
That's,
that's right though.
You want to get it away and destroy it.
So when Hitler came to power,
he put in above a bunch of public health schemes.
Like,
ah,
he had vans that went around and screen people for tuberculosis.
Then he went on a factory cleanliness,
uh,
campaign.
So the factories were supposed to be tidy it up and he washed,
he made about four times a day.
By the way,
it's also a great worship or of willpower,
which is associated with orderliness and seems maybe to be associated with
disgust,
sensitivity in some way that isn't yet understood.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't,
I don't understand that connection either.
So they,
he convinced factory owners in Germany to get rid of the rats and the mice and
mice and insects in the factories and also to clean them up and beautify them.
But the gas they use to clean up the factories was like lawn a,
and it was the variation of that gas cycle on B that was then used in.
Yeah.
So you could see this ramping up pay.
So it was,
yeah,
absolutely.
So it was public health,
then it was social cleanliness.
Then he went into the asylums and cleaned them up.
And so it was just this expansion of,
of who was contaminated and who was impure.
And I think also his fascination with fire and his use of fire symbolism was
also associated with that,
with that appealed to purification because the whole idea of purification by
fire is a very ancient idea.